[Musique]
la fête de la famille s'est déroulée ce
mardi 10 mai à la médiathèque de
Saint-Benoît portée avec passion par les
organismes la fête de la famille est un
dispositif du conseil
départemental alors la journée de la
famille c'est une c'est un spectacle
qu'on a effectué avec les familles c'est
la continuité de travail qu'on a
effectué pendant 3 ans avec les familles
au niveau de de l'accompagnement social
que nous proposons au niveau de la
maison de départementale de saint-benoî
on essaie aussi de complémenter avec du
collectif en valorisant les familles
donc voilà on part à partir des
potentialités des familles et à partir
des talents des familles pour qu'ils
prennent confiance aussi au services
social et pour qu'ils voient aussi
qu'ils ont des potentialités un moment
d'échange et de partage entre parents et
enfants une journée pour resserrer les
liens familiaux dans une ambiance
festive et
détendue alors une journée comme
celle-ci c'est très important pour nous
parce
que notamment en terme de de valeur de
la famille surtout dans la société
actuelle et ça permet aussi de mobiliser
autant les parents autant les enfants
dans un projet très responsable où ils
sont vraiment acteurs de de tout ce qui
est proposé
aujourd'hui au programme de cette
journée pièce de théâtre chant danse
plusieurs spectacles dans lesquels
parents et enfants sont eux même acteurs
et animateurs il y a longtemps qu'on
attendait ça et ben c'est bien comme ça
ça fait bouger ça fait vivre et ben on
est content quand quand on a commencé
j'avis un peu le stress mais après
ça ça par le stress mais même moi je
suis j'ai participé au au spectacle
aussi mais j'ai fait la
j'étais avec les parents on a chanté
voilà on s
amusé Suzy gaps a aidé les familles à
mettre en place les différents
spectacles pour cette enseignante à la
retraite le plus difficile a été de
redonner confiance au jeunes on a fait
appel à moi justement pour encadrer le
groupe théâtre avec ces jeunes en
difficulté et ce fut un réel plaisir
parce que il fallait d'abord les mettre
en confiance avant d'arriver bien sr à
la
scène histoire qu'ils ont écrite
eux-mêmes et c'est ça qui est
intéressant étant donné que ce sont des
enfants comme je viens de vous dire en
difficulté qui n'osait pas s'exprimer
qui n'osait pas s'extérioriser donc il a
fallu faire déjà un travail à ce
niveau-là une journée de partage et de
fêtes où les familles ont pu se
rencontrer échanger mais surtout
s'amuser
[Musique]